[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui je vous le dis ça va être une star
bowl à l'oubli il est en costume est
toujours en tatane en fait c'est son
look
voilà fait toujours certaines ont même
essayé de montrer la vraie c'est bon à
l'idée non mais c'est vrai si on les
voit on lèvera martiaux non mais c'est
bon on les voit qu'on les a vus mais il
a très bien merci d'être là alors
statham qu'est ce que vous allez faire
tous les vendredis eh ben je regarde
tous en fait je vous aime tous du coup
je regarde l'émission tout le temps et
voilà c'est que de l'amour et voilà je
vais débriefer vos performances et les
minions ibo voilà alors dites nous sur
twitter je sens que lui va voir à succès
celui ci et vous savez ce qu'on dit
grant crack petit zizi allez on y va
alors que selon la confiance sa première
télé là où j'y vais alors que s'est il
passé cette semaine est bien bonne
nouvelle christophe carrière est revenu
de ses vacances avec nadège
beausson-diagne françois viot bernard
montiel et philippe vandel on les
embrasse tous un par un mais christophe
n'est pas le seul chroniqueur avoir
faire re ces surfaces ya là aussi on a
entendu parler de l'amca russian a été
chroniqueuse dans tpm paix mais c'est
vrai le temps d'une émission à la menthe
et laisser comme en musique une
apparition intubé ça s'arrête
non non c'est pas vrai arrêter les super
franchement elle est venue chanter faux
ce qui était loin de chez eux
elle est super arrêt sur wii je n'ouvre
les archives de tpm p ouais on regarde
ouais ok ce parti parti
[Musique]
ça va la chouette on est en droit de
perdre le match aller à regarder
l'émission thé ou café dimanche mois
exactement
ouais ouais il connaît tout mais
dimanche matin et mis sur la wii on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler jours mais
j'adore l'émission après l'émission là
mais vous revenez que vous revenez
demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore voyager dames et d'ailleurs
c'est la tête de lemoine à côté kitsch
et oui c'est ça ben alaoui jean luc et
belle impression qu'ont les magic tokyo
le coup d'envoi sport et d'autres choses
pour vous le savez cyril aime dire toute
la vérité au public aux téléspectateurs
résultat capucine nous a révélé en
partie la liste de ses ex
alors on n'a pas pu tous les mentionner
l'autre jour c'était qu'un tpm pixels
jusqu'à 23 heures
mais rassurez vous j'ai laissé les
micros ouverts c'est tout nouveau c'est
pour vous c'est cadeau ça s'appelle la
version très originale de thé pmp
regarder ça à limay voter comment savoir
mon jean milhau
ok comme dame n'a rien compris voilà une
question pour moi petites séries
capucine alors on sait déjà que tu a
chopé cavada apps vous sarkozy et
florent manaudou est ce qu'il y en a
d'autres
ben oui ah bon par exemple tâche mais
françois hollande oui m ghibli
d'achopper sur faire du chan
oui mon pote hakim l'aquitaine kéba part
de la chapelle ben oui supporter surtout
la caserne de pompiers de l'arbaïn oui
et pas qu'un peu
et ont toutes ces tables ben oui ah oui
mais qui fait de l'engager
à part ça les amis j - 7 avant
l'événement médias de ce début d'année
le super bowl pensez vous la nouvelle
saison de koh lanta
oh que non je parlais encore une fois
capus de ton prime une prime à capuche
travailler prochain sera vendu prochain
sur ces 8 est depuis dans monde entier
tout le monde en parle même dans les
talk-shows regarder appelé à la barre
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai une semaine et enfin cette
semaine on a pris encore plein de trucs
hyper intéressant dans l'émission on
appris notamment que cyril pauzet sa
pêche dans les chiottes de son pote jean
rachid
c'était passionnant et pour le reste
j'ai tout résumé en images c'est le
décryptage de tpm p calme-toi quand même
ouais je prends confiance mais je te le
dis oui on commence ce décryptage avec
le chiffre 5 ha soit l'âge mental de
cyril c'est simple un vrai gosses c'est
une émission qui est une adaptation et
en plus de 5 sous la coque d'un format à
part entière c'est un peppers format de
copains un peu profondes
je suis d'abord par une émission qui
avait été tourné par nagui au cube
demandé sinon de leurs mots et ai encore
très très chaud cette semaine c'est
simple le nec a lâché la rampe
d'un autre côté on aurait pu deviner
qu'il était excité de leurs mots il
devait noter l'émission the voice
il hésite entre deux notes 7 et une pub
soit la note maximale pour mathieu
mathieu qui cette semaine encore était
dans la retenue cendre c'est moi les
deux vous savez prix des rideaux de
douche pelouse
[Applaudissements]
allez on retrouve tout de suite notre
couple de retraités nous guetter raymond
à nous c'est l'heure de votre série
préférée ma mini bosque et popi gilou
quand je vois les réflexions que vous
faites sur moi et tout est vraiment un
sous-pull la 23e et lots point fait mais
c'est trop tôt ce qu'elle a dit c'est
toi tais toi et toi on se calme sinon
pendant que woods nesta et oui vous
l'avez compris cette semaine tout le
monde était encore très très chaud
[Musique]
c'était terminé
[Applaudissements]